hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and i've decided a few months ago
as i always say i guess to create my
youtube channel to share
the knowledge to show you guys all the
different
techniques that we have as per traders
to make money on the markets
and i want to show you how to apply
these techniques with some practical
cases
like gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
this is gamestop charts as usual guys
i'm on the forwards time frame to start
the way i actually work is that i have
my moving averages
i do my drawings you know using trend
lines idiot waves
counting and i try to see if something
looks working in the past for example if
i have a moving average that is giving
me
a lot of reactions so on the flowers
time frame
i don't see anything very clear so i go
you know i zoom in a little bit right i
zoom in
and i check and when you do this guys
what do you see all right
just have a look here look at the moving
averages
and especially the most recent past is
the best do you see something here for
example that
looks like is reacting well pretty
obvious right
the 50 period moving average on the
hourly timeframe
has acted guys as a perfect support
in the two last trading days all right
so this is our support level on the
short term
clearly identified there is no doubt
about it if this breaks
80 percent chance that you're gonna see
a breakout and the price action
drifting lower so this is what you need
to keep
an eye on if you are a day trader if you
trade on a short time frame
if i take a step back so i'm gonna stay
on the hourly time frame for now
once again what we're looking for guys
we're looking for some
bullish sign some bullish upside
breakout
so to do that as i showed you guys
before
you need to identify your waves so you
have one here i can
draw them again quickly you have your
abc here
all right and you have here the
correction
and here we have an abc as well
i can do it like this you know it
doesn't really matter
we are not sure this abc is complete by
the way okay so this is something you
need to keep in mind
we are not sure that you know it it can
be like this guys all right it can be
like
a b c with the c wave doing a
one two three it can be like this
all right so it's not because in every a
and c wave you can find an abc and in
the b wave all right it's actually x
y z corrections it's the same you know i
use abc
some traders likes like to use uh x y z
w x y sorry and you know
find corrections like this it's exactly
the same it's just that you need to have
three waves in each of these waves i
mean it's not very
important so uh what i'm saying is that
we're not sure that we bottomed here
it could be possible uh and what we're
looking for is actually a sign of
completion
of our wave that is here so let me level
it again sorry for that
up we are looking for a sign of
completion of
this wave a wave is complete whenever
you have
a breakout if it's a corrective wave we
are looking for an upside breakout so to
find a breakout once again guys you use
trend lines
and you connect you know the recent
highs that you have
it's working pretty much everywhere guys
all right it has worked here
okay so this one i i showed you guys
this one you know
we have this this strong rebound here
like plus three percent
and then correction perfectly on the
trend line that is here i'm not sure you
guys can see it very well
you know this was in the past so this
one so it worked on this one
and it's gonna probably work on this one
as well and you can even do it on the
shorter time frame as i showed you guys
already this but you know it's always
good to see things
many times so you remember better you
know
same here you have a wave and bam when
this
wave is complete when we have two
candles trading above the trend line
that is created by uh connecting the two
highs we had in this wave all right so
just to show you guys that this
technique is working well and once again
it's something that i use every day
and if i say 80 percent of the time i
think it's something that makes sense
you know a breakout
that confirmed breakout usually gives
you good
results 80 percent of the time sometimes
it's what we call a fake breakout you
know this is trading you know there is
nothing you know for certain you always
need to keep in mind
that your scenario is always a preferred
scenario and that
anything can happen right and you need
to be prepared
for this anything that can happen
anytime so here we are looking for
a breakout of this trend line so
something like this up up up this
would be a breakout and this would
actually
confirmed that we are going higher as
long as we are below
this trend line the trend is gonna shift
uh
lower but what is good about those
corrective waves
is that actually as you can see my trend
line is going lower so even if the price
action
doesn't move until the 23rd of april
21st sorry even before here around like
20th
of april so the trendline is going to be
broken by itself just
uh by the time coming to us so this is
you know just be patient and if the
price action doesn't go over
you're gonna have your bullish signal
all right so this is what we're looking
for and once again 175
here is for me a critical level that we
need to trade above
to see some bullish momentum coming back
in the game
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys